okay so we'll need to afford all of our  mail and change our address on all the  accounts are you listening to me are you  thinking about bubble wrap it's like  fireworks in our home okay I just  updated our auto insurance to the new  address and got us homeowners insurance  awesome  Thank You Lee for this what we're gonna  need more boxes can I have that box hey  Sam great blender are you gonna get rid  of that box think about it  I don't think we need movers we  definitely need new person that much  stuff those are empty see I hope you  didn't gave movers when did we get that  Oh God so bigger Wow  it's so clean we should become  minimalists yeah I'm gonna put my 80s  VHS tapes here  this isn't kind of be like a music jam  guitar space minimalist yeah exactly  [Music]  Wow we have a huge guard perfect  oh yeah  [Music]  can I have that box  [Music]